britain's prince andrew has been
stripped of his military affiliations
and royal patronages the prince will
also stop using his royal highness title
in any official capacity andrew is
facing a civil case in the u.s over
allegations he sexually assaulted a
woman when she was 17.
virginia dufrese is suing the prince
claiming he abused her in 2001.
for prince andrew seen here with his
accuser virginia jeffrey in 2001 it's
the problem that just won't go away the
queen's second son now faces trial in
the u.s after a judge refused to throw
out the case against him andrew now
finds himself completely removed from
official royal life after buckingham
palace released a statement stripping
him of his military roles in royal
patronages he had already permanently
resigned from public duties in 2020
many in london welcomed the move by the
royal family
i think that you know if there's any
kind of guilt or there's
any chance that he's done it then
you know maybe maybe it's a good
precautionary measure i'm really happy
that the royal family isn't defending
him anymore and that he's private
citizen defending his own case
so i hope the justice will be served but
there's still a long legal battle ahead
for andrew and his accuser joffrey she
says she was forced into sex with the
royal by the late sex defender jeffrey
epstein and his associate gelaine
maxwell who was recently convicted of
sex trafficking both were long-time
friends of the prince who was always
strenuously denied delegations
but with the long and embarrassing saga
set to become even more public andrew's
effective removal makes it clear that
for the royal family enough was enough